I never post those tropes it's here I am
chopping you and thirst but first
chrissy teigen is clapping back at the
haters in a classically chrissy way we
all have different body types and what
works for my body doesn't work for the
next person it what works for that
person doesn't work for me the whole
thing started after chrissy shared a
video of herself standing in front of a
mirror wearing a super sexy black
one-piece swimsuit i never posted those
tropes it's here i am chopping you and
thirst but first fire right well the
internet trolls did what the trolls do
trolls part one Twitter user said that
her body was quote shaped like spongebob
Chrissie shut that ish down fast calling
the tweet super mean I'm not gonna ever
have those curves and that ass and that
waistline that's just not my body and
I'm fine with that
I really am but it wasn't all criticism
in fact one fan sent some love to the
model tweeting I'm sorry everyone is
being so rude to you you're so beautiful
inside and out and another fan shared
their support writing so Chrissy Teigen
posted a quick vid of herself in a body
suit and the world went on attack men
and women both throwing insults I only
wish I could look like her when did all
these hats become walking perfect Ken
and Barbies hashtag douche bags
Chrissy's response everyone used to
surgically enhanced curves I've been
asked where my whole life and let me
tell you it's paid off nicely in many
ways I think of really mean things and
I'm like I can't say that so I say it
out loud to everyone around me
then I typed something a little tame
then Chrissy who's married to John
Legend shared her take on how people
would respond if she showed up one day
with a curvier figure quote oh you guys
would be pissed then - I'm happy
John's happy we all happy and doing
a-okay there's just different times of
the day where I'm more sensitive to
things than another time of day or you
know we all have bad days when you hear
something negative on that particular
bad day it might hit you worse than it
did it would have the day before or
something back in 2018
Chrissy opened up to et about why she
fires back at the haters online everyone
has feelings and I think it's important
for people to see that's why I do like
to clap back as they call it because I
like people to know that you know we're
not just robots that are just like on
this other side of the computer and we
don't see everything I see everything
and I think more than a lot of people I
read a lot and and it gets to you for
sure it definitely gets to you but it
helps to be it helps to like have a
wonderful family life and a good career
[Music]